wieso braucht es die Anna im EU Parlament?
weil sie herzenswarm ist
für neuen Schwung im EU Parlament,
weil wir eine Junge Stimme brauchen,
weil es mehr Junge Frauen in der Politik braucht.
ich glaub die Welt braucht generell mehr Anders.
aber im EU Parlament braucht sie Anna,
weil sie sich für die richtigen Themen einsetzt
und mit vollem Herz bei der Sache ist.
weil ich glaube das ist unglaublich wichtig ist,
dass wir Junge,
engagierte
und intelligente Menschen nach Europa schicken,
was für mehr Junge
motivierte Frauen braucht,
die für Europa stehen und auch für Europa
der zukünftigen Generationen.
die Anna braucht zum EU Parlament,
weil ich unbedingt die junge Generation brauch,
die Europa auch wirklich in
seiner urpositivsten Form in dieses Parlament bringt.
und ich weiß, die Anna wird es machen,
weil wir mehr Junge Menschen brauchen,
die wirklich für die Sache brennen.
und das tut die andere.
und die andere ist eine der kompetentesten und
intelligentesten Menschen,
die ich kenne
und ich hoffe wirklich, dass sie reinkommt.
weil Anna aufzeigt, dass alles möglich ist,
dass man alles unter n Hut kriegen kann,
wenn man nur will.